[Music]
the big bang our best understanding of
cosmic Origins was a brief period of the
most intense conditions colossal density
and ferocious
temperature but as space expanded
conditions calmed the universe mellowed
and the temperature steadily dropped
today the prime remnant of that early
intense heat is the cosmic microwave
background radiation a cosmological
Afterglow of the universe's fiery
beginning the microwave background was
predicted in the 1940s through the
combined insights of Ralph alfur Robert
Hermon and George gamau and in 1965 was
detected by Arno penus and Robert Wilson
but it was the launch of the Kobe
mission in
1992 spearheaded by John Mather and his
team that ushered in the era of precise
measurements of the microwave background
radiation and with it the era of
precision cosmological understanding
earning Mather and his colleague George
Smoot the Nobel Prize in
physics that accomplishment alone would
Crown any scientific career but John
Mather went on from there to lead
another breakthrough science project the
James web Space Telescope matter spent
the better part of three decades leading
James web scientist from design to
launch and though still in its early
phases the results have already been
spectacular the clarity and resolution
of the web telescope's images are
nothing short of stunning taking us a
giant Step Beyond those provided by
web's predecessor the law Ed Hubble
Space Telescope providing data that is
already inspiring scientists to rethink
a leld understanding of how the early
Universe evolved and if John Mather's
second act was as brilliant as his first
he's not stopping there he has just left
his leadership role at James web to
embark on a new adventure planning for
the hybrid Observatory that will search
for earthlike
exoplanets seeking what many see as the
Great
discovery of all life beyond
Earth John Mather is one of the most
influential astrophysicists and
cosmologists of our time playing
formative and pivotal roles in
groundbreaking undertakings including
the cosmic background Explorer mission
that earned him a Nobel Prize and while
recently with the James web Space
Telescope that is already returning
spectacular data which promises deep
insights into the nature of the universe
and so it is my great pleasure to
welcome John Mather to our stage welcome
John thank you R I just want to start
right at the end as opposed to starting
at the beginning the James web Space
Telescope he been out there for a while
it is doing some wonderful work what
would you say are the one or two big
insights or discoveries or surprises
that so far have come up from the
machine well the one big surprise we've
our feeling is that the early galaxies
grew much quicker than we thought they
would they're bigger brighter hotter
more massive than people expected and we
don't know yet what's different between
our plan for the universe and the actual
Universe right and so when were the
earliest of these galaxies then forming
the first ones we know about are about
two or 3 hundred million years after the
big bang so that's pretty far back it's
a what we call a red shift of 12 13 14
even and what would you have thought
based upon on things that we knew before
the web was up there we thought we'd see
that far but we didn't think we would
see what we're seeing yeah we thought
the galaxies would be smaller cooler
darker and now we are surprised we just
don't know why they're that way are
there any great ideas bubbling up well
there are a few so the big question is
what are the first stars like the stars
today are most of them are like the sun
a little bit smaller a little bit bigger
it's possible that the very first ones
were thou hundreds or thousands of times
as massive as the sun that they would
burn out very quickly sure uh and very
quickly release vast amounts of the
heavier chemical elements besides
hydrogen and helium so that's a
possibility we're working on there's
also the big question of where did the
first black holes come from these days
every galaxy has a big fat black hole in
the middle and we don't know whether
that was produced before the galaxies or
after the galaxies so this wide open
question yeah hugely interesting in
terms of the machine machine itself and
later on I'd like to come back to a
little of the history of how James web
came to be but so far in terms of it's
functioning what would you grade it you
know ABC how's it doing it's an A++ A++
it is doing so beautifully uh the
optical quality is about twice as good
as we promised really and it wasn't
because you under promised to be able to
overd deliver this is really no this is
um it could have been different yeah we
have to allow for things that could go
wrong right and so you always plan for
it to be a little better than the
requirement and then you hope nothing
bad happens right so nothing bad
happened and so with with 2020 hindsight
as you look back on the design decisions
that were made have you learned anything
where you've taken a step back and say
ah I just wish we would have known that
we would have done something differently
not really uh everything is pretty much
the way we hoped it would be um you
could imagine then next time when we
build the next B telescope it make some
different decisions but the purpose will
be different by then U this web
telescope will accomplish its main
mission of studying the infrared light
uh from the most distant universe and
from cool objects from dtin shrouded
objects so the next one will be
different and it will'll make some
different decisions about that one and
in terms of uh the fuel capacity you
there are various estimates of how long
web would stick around as a functioning
device how's that going we're expecting
to much longer than the original expect
ation we were expecting maybe 11 or 12
years of scientific life and we're
looking like 20 or more really more than
20 more than 20 and the reason is
twofold number one uh that we got a
effectively perfect rocket launch that
took us exactly where we wanted to go
didn't have to spend extra fuel on
dealing with that and we're seeming to
drive our sports car better than we
thought we would terms of reorienting we
don't have to reorient it so often wow
well that's that's that's just
spectacular so let's take a a step back
if if you would your your upbringing you
grew up I gather in in New Jersey and
sort of farm area is that correct yeah I
grew up on a research Farm of rers
University oh was a research farm and my
dad was studying dairy cows to see if we
get more and better milk is that right
from breeding better cows so that was U
started back in the 1920s and and why
didn't you then go into biology was that
well it wasn't so exciting at the time
yeah nowadays extremely exciting because
we've got all the tools of genetics and
subcellular resolution with tools that
we just didn't have 50 70 years ago so
it was exciting but not as exciting as
astronomy right and so how did you make
that turn I mean was astronomy you
picked it up you television show school
class or I I think astronomy turned up
right away when I was in third grade I
remember we had biographies of Galileo
and Darwin in the house so I'm reading
them by fourth grade I'm reading
everything I can get about any every
kind of science but astronomy was just
really exciting because there's not much
known but there's some pretty exciting
things so for instance I visited the
Museum of Natural History here in New
York City oh really I grew up across the
street from it it had big influence on
me yeah so I saw the giant mediaite that
sits there and uh where did that come
from yeah um where did the Earth come
from so the minute you see this stuff
where did it all come from well
astronomy gets of that and at the time
very little was known yeah um people had
no idea how the Sun was formed how the
planets were formed the stories that you
could get in books were wrong yeah okay
so some we got to work on this and so
did you for instance have a a little
telescope when yeah I got my lenses from
medman scientific and I got cardboard
tubes and I made my telescopes then in
high school I saved up my money to get a
a mirror for a better telescope so yeah
I had my telescope at home with plywood
and pipes and all kinds of things to
make it go now I I personally was never
never a builder tinkerer I was always in
the mathematics so it was clear for me
from the GetGo that I was going to if I
was going to go into science it would be
as a theorist you also started in the
theoretical Direction even though as a
youngster you were clearly working on
things with your hands was there
Confluence or tension between them no I
was really eager to be a theoretical
physicist because I had a summer course
at Cornell in high school and it was
covered gravitation and relativity qu
mechan
radioactivity
interferometry anyway that was the
coolest thing and I thought we were just
discovering the basic Elementary
particles at the time sure so I want to
work on that when I got to graduate
school I said well should I become a
theoretical physicist and the adviser
said no there no jobs for those people
are you rich no I'm not rich so I was
also eager to touch something yeah so I
found a laboratory project which was to
measure the cosmic microwave background
radiation and how did that project emerg
well um that was just five a few years
after the discovery of the radiation in
1965 and five years later I'm looking
for a thesis project so yeah start off
building something on a Mountaintop to
measure the radiation and we I worked
with Mike Werner and we made made the
instrument and it worked but there's not
much you can see from there so then my
thesis adviser was Paul Richards and he
came back with a design we're going to
build this uh apparatus and send it up
on a balloon hanging on a string Under a
balloon so was a great idea but the
first time we launched it did not work
oh is that right so I had already lined
up a postto position here in New York
city so okay I'll go off to New York and
I'll write a thesis about a thing that
didn't work so then I'm sitting here in
New York is that is that what you did
your thesis was about the experiment and
there was is there it's an interesting
question as a theorist I don't actually
even know the answer to this if you
doing an experiment and it doesn't work
is it guaranteed that you will succeed
in getting your your doctor no um we had
to prove that I could do research that I
could build equipment so we had the
boring but working project we had done
on the mountain toop right had some
papers out so there enough right but not
so thrilling but we had no idea what was
going to happen next right and the and
the post talk when you say it was in New
York was it's the
gued yes just down the road from here
yeah because as a kid Broadway I I
wonder if we overlap there because when
I was in high school I had a summer job
there doing various things with the
landsat satellite that they used to do
in the I wonder our I think our tractors
were close yeah so yeah so that's where
I was in in the summer of
74 little bit earlier I guess than I was
yeah so um that was the summer that NASA
said we want Mission proposals science
missions so it's five years after the
moonlanding at that point and they
wanted to know what they were going to
do well we can't keep on doing
moonlanding
so what's next so I said boss my thesis
project failed we should try it in outer
space he said we'll call up our friends
we write a proposal and we did so it was
pretty thin I had a drawing that I made
about how the satellite would look and
we had a good team really smart people
but we none of us had ever done a
satellite Mission before hardly anybody
else had either yeah sure so okay well
good idea so couple of years later it
looked like NASA might really choose to
to do this project so I moved to the big
laboratory in greenv Maryland where I've
been ever since and we made that thing
happen so 15 years from napkin sketch to
lunch and this is Kobe this is Kobe
satellite so so again just to many
people in our audience will be familiar
but for those who aren't this is all
about measuring the cosmic microwave
background radiation so can we just
before getting to Kobe itself can we
just step back and and understand why
why people thought there might be this
background radiation and then a little
bit of the history of of its Discovery
so this all emerges from The Big Bang
idea about cosmology so I've spoken
about this a billion times so have you
but I'm going to throw it to to just
give us the overview of what the big
bang is so sure the fundamental
observation was uh Edwin Hubble Drew us
a graph that shows the distant galaxies
are going away from us with a speed
roughly proportional to distance 1929
so okay imagine backwards what happened
when the universe was young they were
all squished together in some way and so
that was all they really knew at that
time then people said well we should be
able to calculate something so in 1948
Alfred and Herman calculated if the
universe is expanding like this what if
was hot when it was young and they
calculated the temperature that it
should have and they got it about right
so they were about like five 5 degrees
so okay so what should we be looking for
the entire Sky should be covered with
heat radiation uh at a wavelengths of a
few millimeters so nobody went to look
at that point and they tried I gather to
convince some people to look um yeah
people tried to convince somebody to to
measure but nobody actually took it on
yeah if they known there was a Nobel
Prize waiting for them they would have
tried that's the interesting thing so
why when this notion came to light no
pun intended did nobody take it
seriously enough to look were there too
many other exting things at the time
with nuclear physics clearly something
if you know it's really really hard and
you don't know how to do it at all then
who's got the courage to start right so
this was 1948 we didn't have the
technology we have today yes you
couldn't buy liquid helium you couldn't
buy the stuff you needed to buy so it
was hard so the actual Discovery
happened in 1965 right here in New
Jersey at the Bell Telephone Labs where
they were not looking for it but they
had the equipment that could do it so
that's uh almost two decades of
Technology progress that they had to use
so that worked so quick question on that
so that's of course the famous pendus
and Wilson and and then there's a
beautiful story with Bob Dicky and and
various collaborators who were on the
theoretical but also the experimental
and Ralph alfur you know I've read a bit
about his history felt pretty bad for
many years because you know he and
Herman first having this discovery
nobody pays attention and then gets
rediscovered you know in the
60s do you do you think that Ralph
Alfred never got his due on that well he
clearly was not recognized for what he
had done at the time they had done it
although when he gave his thesis defense
300 people came to watch him do it is
that right it's so it wasn't like nobody
knew yeah um but he did not take up a
university position with graduate
students and universities to back him up
it's one factor yeah also when the
discovery was made the people that made
the Discovery did not site the original
papers and did they know about that that
think it's a little controversial right
well they did know because Alfred was a
reviewer and he told them really yeah
but they still refus to cite it why do
not know cannot speak about that part
why people do what they do wow but
anyway I had this from Al his voice
directly and there's a record of his
interview and there's records that show
that he was right so anyway they didn't
cite it so he didn't get his credit yeah
and so he had reason to be an
amazing so people made a choice not to
cite his work and they could have chosen
better huh so yeah that's a some painful
to hear yeah so he didn't like that for
good reason right So eventually he was
recognized for his work um and so we
invited him and and Herman to come to
the launch of the Kobe satellite they
were really thrilled to do that yeah and
so you noted that from napkin sketch to
launch was what 15 or so years what are
you doing during those 15 years is it
daytoday focused on making this happen
absolutely you're running like crazy to
figure out how to solve every single
problem because once you say you're
going to do it then you say you have to
do it so now you don't know the answer
to what you're going to do today
tomorrow or the next day and you've got
this immense list of Technology problems
so you don't have the detectors you
don't have the system design you don't
know how to order into the satellite so
you start off with meetings with
Engineers um all the time all the time
and are you explaining to the
fundamental science that that we are
like immersed in a in a bath of heat
left over from The Big Bang we just want
to measure that heat is that part of we
explained all that and in fact uh
although I didn't take it too seriously
at the time everybody else knew that
this was a Nobel winning project right I
said I'm not thinking about
it I'm just going to work right right in
fact in principle it's well I mean
nobble prizes you have to find something
but if you didn't find it that would
even be more shocking true it would be
more shocking so of course what did we
find well number one we confirmed the
prediction of the spectrum how bright is
this radiation at each different
wavelength and so the prediction of the
early universe is like you're looking at
a oven and scientists have a name for
this curve it's called a black body
curve and so we made our own little
black body we put it up in space and set
it to the right temperature and it
matched the sky exactly at first it was
for 1% accuracy eventually 50 parts per
million which is better than we'd ever
done any kind of experiment of that sort
before or since so number one check that
color uh so then number two Discovery
was so before we go to that which is a
key Next Step just if we can unpack the
first discovery a little bit more so you
announced this result at a at a famous
meeting can and where you showed that
black Body Curve and you showed the data
points can you give a sense of what that
meeting was like and how your work was
received so well it was a Saturday and I
thought oh it's Saturday our project
isn't very important so people aren't
coming on
Saturday everybody that could come was
there on Saturday and and where was it
it was in Washington DC for the
Astronomical Society meeting and maybe
1500 or 2,000 people were packed into
this Auditorium wow so my golly so this
is more important than I thought and and
I then I put my little graph of the
spectrum on The View graph machine this
just plastic view graphs and I just said
it there and after a moment uh people
started they all stood up and cheered
wow for a graph yeah so okay then we did
something that matters a lot to a lot of
people right so there's huge excitement
yeah Standing Ovation for a graph and
and which is amazing and before we get
to the next step what would you say was
the the import of the match between the
black Body Curve as theoretical
physicists can plot it and the actual
data that matched it so precisely okay
well the import is that the hot big bang
is the only story that matches uh it
predicts exactly this curve and none of
the other stories did so we had two
interesting competing stories one was
maybe the early Universe was cold when
it started and it heated itself up later
the other idea was something called the
steady state Theory yeah which is a bit
implausible of its own but it said the
age of the universe is infinity not a
finite number like 15 billion
uh and so there's a mysterious process
that refills the universe as it expands
so giving an additional matter creating
additional matter to diluting density so
that was pretty impossible but at any
rate neither of those Alternatives fit
the measurements at all right so okay so
the Big Bang story is probably right and
and and if we can just spend a moment on
on the Big Bang in that now there's huge
motivation to really understand what
this theory is telling us about the
universe since this prediction from this
approach is matching exactly what the
observations are showing there's a lot
of misconceptions I think about the big
bang and if we can sort of just take a
slight left turn and talk about those
for a moment so one of them is and look
I'm as guilty of this as anyone but if
anyone asks I always then try to repair
the era in the way I describe it we like
to think about the universe you know it
all comes from a little tiny dck
and that that and this always gives
people the wrong impression of a DOT
within space that sort of exploded
outward and and filled space so can you
clear us from this misconception yeah so
maybe we should start with the right
picture first yes um the right picture
that I think we have is that the
universe is infinite in all directions
in space uh so that means as far as you
can imagine there's always more so just
keep on imagining that's there's always
more
there's a limit to how far you can
actually see because the universe has an
age and light travels at a certain speed
so you just can't see all the way so
there's not really an edge but you it
feels like there is because you're
looking back in time as you're looking
out in space however there's a there is
a finite age you look back in
imagination uh towards the earliest
moments um you can't go past a certain
spot yep so the way I think about it
that's a what we call a singularity in
time not in space so a singularity is a
a region of something where the
something go becomes Unlimited in amount
so the temperature and the density are
unlimited as we get back towards the
very first moments we can imagine right
so that's what we call a singularity so
in mathematics we have a s simple one
simple one we can talk about just
imagine one overx where X is a number um
and as X gets smaller and smaller and
smaller one overx gets bigger and bigger
and bigger so that's the classic
mathematical simple example of of a
singularity it's it's x equals z is not
allowed right so that's like you can't
compress everything into a point either
even in that simple example but the
neighborhood of x equal to zero is
really interesting that's why we call
the singularity is a neighborhood around
a spot and so we don't understand that
one so um in our case the neighborhood
of Time Zero is a singularity in time
but Time Zero is itself not allowed in
this story so not to say that time zero
couldn't exist in some other story but
that's the way we do it at the moment
yeah obviously we theorists would love
to push time ever closer to zero or even
even before but you're absolutely right
I mean the way I think about Singularity
is it's Nature's way of telling us that
your math has not accurately described
things yet it's as if the math grabs you
by the lapel and slaps you and says pay
attention something's going wrong
so euphemism for we don't know really
what's going on that's exactly how I say
it too when you run out of imagination
that's what we call the time zero or the
or the uh the Big Bang so of course we
have lots of marvelous stories about
inflation and other things that people
have used to explain all of this but the
fundamental issue is we just don't know
right as we imagine trying to get back
towards very early times we get to where
we think quantum mechanics ought to
govern gravity in which case time itself
becomes uncertain right and that place
well I hand it over to you now what do
we do I wish I could give you the full
answer to that one but uh I'll pass the
Hot Potato back um so that's why we call
it the Big Bang because it found but
it's a bad name yeah and we have it
because sir Fred Hoy gave it that name
because he hated the whole idea in a
radio interview that was supposedly a
little disparaging yeah so anyway so
it's stuck so people hear the name and
they think of the firecracker in a
pre-existing space in time yeah so we
can't help thinking of it so but then it
makes us crazy because it's wrong yeah
and so um if one does imagine that the
universe is infinite again that's an
interesting question to come back to in
a split second because we don't know
that it's we couldn't possibly know that
yeah but if it is infinite then this era
of incredibly high density and
Incredibly high temperature that the
Universe gets near as time gets ever
closer to zero that would be true
everywhere over this infinite expanse so
rather than it being just a little d
where this Singularity is taking place
it would be the full
spal but but what if the universe is
finite let's say we're let's say it goes
on really far well beyond say the
observable part that we have direct
access to then it could be that it all
gets ever smaller toward the Big Bang
but now it's not within a pre-existing
space which is often the era of
visualization that people bring to this
picture yeah so that's tricky and it
gets to what's the shape of space itself
yeah so we have descriptions of curved
space and uh some people say well curve
space is positively curved like the
surface of the Earth Yep uh or it could
be flat or it could be negatively curved
like the surface of a saddle Y and
evidence is from measurement it's pretty
close to Flat um but it's a long story
yep could be flat and toroidal though in
principle so there's some weird stuff
with the topology but that will take us
too far
any this you know way of thinking the
big bang for argument s let's imagine
it's infinite got this hugely high
temperature near time zero and as the
infinite expanse expands the temperature
gets lower and lower what temperature
then would we expect it to be today
based on our understanding well um we
wouldn't have been able to predict it
alone but we but Alfred and Herman got
pretty close with 5 Kelvin we measured
2.7 2.7 Kelvin and so seems to be very
Min the same wherever you look also
right now you were making reference to
the fact that it would be problematic if
it was absolutely the same temperature
in absolutely every direction why would
that be problematic why would you not
expect that we would not expect that
because something made galaxies yeah and
the only idea we have for what would
make galaxies that's still holding up is
gravity operating on the primordial
material would stop the expansion
somewhere so if there's totally uniform
which way is gravity going to pull yeah
there's no Direction preferred so there
has to be something that says some
spaces are different from others so okay
in that case something got higher
density and some things got lower
density there should be hot and cold
spots in the radiation so that was a
pretty definite prediction by the time
we launched the Kobe satellite when we
started conceiving it there was no
definite prediction whatever we just
knew we have to go measure right and so
is that a separate part of the
measurement apparatus yes we had a whole
separate instrument that was to make a
map of the microwave radiation and it
was done with a more traditional
microwave receiver technology with the
transistors and diodes and things like
that and how accurate was in other words
how big could the or I should say how
small could the anisotropies be and
still be measured with the device that
you put up we measured a an isot which
is a fractional variation of temperature
about a part in 100,000 part in 100,000
so the temperature is about 2.7 de that
means we're looking for temperature
variations of about 30 micro degrees
comparing one part of the sky with
another was that well within the
measurability of the apparatus it was
just barely possible for us okay uh in
fact our project was delayed for a while
because Hubble Telescope needed more
money and so okay well what are we going
to do so you actually had funding that
was cut because of we couldn't keep up
so okay Hubble had very high priority
for good reason of okay so what are we
going to do we've got another year or
two can we improve the technology so we
said yes let's try this new improved one
so we did that and because we did that
we were able to make the discovery wow
and Challenger also had an impact on
yeah Challenger held us up because the
original plan was Kobe would go up on a
space shuttle uh to be launched from
California
and they never did launch any from
California but we would have gone U but
then the Challenger said no we not doing
that better redesign this for a more
conventional rocket a Delta rocket and
there were no Delta Rockets um but there
were some spare parts around are you're
kidding me so people found the spare
parts just enough to put a whole rocket
together and that was a bit of
excitement too number one first you have
to find the rocket then you have to
repair the pieces that have been damaged
by pigeon poop that have been eating
through the aluminum and then you have
enough and you say you can do this then
the other thing is you have to redesign
the satellite because it was to go in a
space shuttle which is huge and now
we're going into a much smaller rocket
so we what kind of a redesign was that
huge it was a huge effort I have to lose
half the mass um now most of it we
didn't need anymore because it was
because we were going on the shut we
needed that um but half the mass much
smaller in total dimensions so hurry up
and fix this so we went uh and it was
recognized that soon after the
Challenger that we could be the next
NASA mission after the Challenger so we
were so me everybody now is pushing go
as fast as you can yeah so we did and
then launch was what date November 18th
of 1989 wow from California from
Vandenburg Air Force Base in California
in Loke and it was a early morning
launch it was cold as it's always cold
in the morning and then the rocket went
up U and pretty soon we saw that had
survived a major challenge which is when
the wind blows up there it could shake
the rocket and what we saw was a the
contrail from the rocket engine went up
and up and up and then there was a loop
like this which meant that a at a
certain altitude the wind suddenly came
up so it could have rocket could have
hurt the rocket but it didn't wow and
and so it was a success it was a su
satellite is launched and immediately is
it doing what it needed to do or there
moments there where you're we had a a
scary moment because there are things
called Gyros that are used to control or
they sense how the satellite is rotating
one of them failed within a few days so
I'm and how many are there on on
altogether two sets of four so we were
okay but of course I'd been at the lab
until 3:00 in the morning I went home to
sleep and the phone rang oh so you've
lost the
mission no better go back to work yeah
so as it turned out of course the
engineers had designed with this with
this possibility to mind it
automatically did the right thing so
enough redundancy yeah plenty of
redundancy going stuff happens yeah for
sure and so it begins to take data how
long does it take for you to begin to
see that it's getting some pretty good
data well we knew right away that it was
working yeah um it took us six weeks
about to get the first scientific result
ready for publication so and that was a
black body black Body Curve so that was
that was a big hurry yeah and we were so
thrilled because it worked yeah amazing
and then we move on to the
anisotropies and so you have the means
of measuring and those begin to become
apparent in the data how long does that
take it took us about two years before
we really sure we'd seen something so of
course right away you see the the data
are coming in but here the what we call
signal to noise ratio whether it's how
big is a signal compared with a fuzz on
the signal yeah it's first it's very
small so you have to add up hundreds of
millions of measurements in the computer
that are repeats of the same thing and
also comparing one piece of the sky with
another so a very complicated computer
program runs to take bits that don't
show you anything and add them up enough
so you can see the pattern and so we
have actually I think a an image of uh
what we refering to so what are we what
are we seeing here can you just give us
a sense okay well the hot the different
colors refer to temperature and the uh
the average temperature we're not
showing here is 2.7 25 Kelvin about U
and we see variations in the colors
which are plus or minus aart in 100,000
about 30 micro degrees so that's what
those big colored blobs are about yeah
and uh the reason they're big is that's
how sharp the image is that we can make
with the equipment which is little
microwave receivers with antennas little
horn antennas subsequent equipment had
bigger telescopes with focusing mirrors
and got much sharper pictures yeah I
think we even have uh I guess maybe W
map yeah that's the successor equipment
yeah a w map was built by many of the
same people that built the Kobe
satellite and were you involved in W I
was not only in the very Beginnings okay
because I started working on the web
telescope immed immed after second work
on the wmap Y and so the the Speckles
that we have here are giving us an
understanding of those centers of
gravity around which matter can coales
through the gravitational force
ultimately giving rise to the structures
that we see in the night sky without
those variations we'd be perplexed why
there's any structure at all absolutely
so just to give us um again a little bit
of a a turn into the theoretical
Direction
what's our understanding of where these
little temperature variations come from
why and we know the role that they play
but why they come from I guess the
prevalent guess is that they're due to
Quantum Mechanics afflicting or
infecting or bothering the the very
first primordial material whatever it
was and so since we don't know what it
was we can just say well it's quantum
mechanics yeah which is like well I
don't understand it it must be quantum
mechanics but there are some pretty
power ful calculations which allow us at
least in certain theoretical Frameworks
so there is a a theory called inflation
that says well I don't know how it
started but here is how it work if it
started yeah and so it makes a
prediction of a number which might have
been one but turns out to be 097 or so
and so measurement says it's 097 so it
confirms that story of the inflation
right although it doesn't say what made
the bumps it says the inflation
stretched out the bumps to give this
particular particular design right of
how many big ones and how many little
ones there are yeah so that's pretty
shocking it's beautiful When Alan Guth
first told us about this I thought we'll
never have any clue and I did not know
there was a calculation they could make
that we could test yeah yeah no it's
it's a beautiful idea where primordial
Quantum fluctuations from uncertainty
stretched by inflationary cosmology
yields of prediction which when
understood correctly matches the
statistical distribution of the hot and
cold spots it's like there's quantum
mechanics r large across the night sky
in a beautiful Confluence of all these I
never guessed it would ever be testable
yeah so it's a it's it's a it's a
wonderful story of success but even so
there are others who claim there are
alternative stories theories that can do
just as well that don't make use of
inflationary cosmology so it's still a
beautifully Rich Arena of discovery that
that's still going on yes and since none
of these theories stum from something
even more
fundamental we're just stuck with well
this is our guess we contest it against
the evidence yeah but it doesn't yet
allow us to say this is the only answer
right yeah we certainly hope with other
ideas string the UniFi you know things
that I and many others have spent
decades on that will one day be able to
with some degree of confidence answer
some of these questions but certainly
you're absolutely right we we can't do
that yet so well we've got some
requirements of those theories we got to
do three things got to explain those
spots got to explain dark matter and
dark energy and none of them were
predicted by anybody else yeah so
there's a test there for whoever does
answer this question and maybe it'll be
your story maybe who knows yeah no
you're right Dark Matter Dark Energy
many people don't fully realize this
we're brought in as patches in a way to
fix up existing Theory to make it match
subsequent observations and um they're
very natural ideas compelling ideas but
until we capture a dark matter particle
until we actually can measure the dark
energy directly these are just
hypothetical fixes you're absolutely
right people have been working for
decades with better and better and
bigger and bigger equipment no dark M
matter particles here were you ever
tempted to go into the dark matter
business directly no I thought that's
too
hard because there's no guarantee
there's anything there to find true true
so I like working on sure things yeah
well actually that's a that's a good way
of putting it so so back to to your
particular story so
Kobe confirms the black body Spectrum
finds the
anisotropies do you start to think about
Nobel Prize coming your way a little bit
more than you had earlier on actually
not really in uh '94 when we wrapped up
the operations for the web for the Kobe
satellite I thought okay now what am we
doing do now and so it was about a year
and a half later phone call from NASA
headquarters we're studying this to
telescope do you want to work on it yeah
okay I call them back yes I want to work
on it drop drop everything else and that
was the other sure thing that I wanted
to work on I don't know whether the
world thinks that's a Nobel Prize
Discovery over there but I do know if we
can build this new telescope it is the
coolest thing I've ever heard of right
so I'm going to work on it and this is
the James web the James web telescope
back then it was called the Next
Generation Space Telescope after Star
Trek and Star Wars and uh yeah amazing
and and and so so the idea here was to
focus on infrared radiation can you just
give us a motivation for sure so when we
built the Hubble telescope we said this
is the best we can build now uh and we
can make it warm and it'll measure as
well as you can possibly measure visible
light yeah so then we flew it and we saw
immediately there's a lot more to know
uh at longer wavelengths and Things You
couldn't possibly see with a Hubble no
matter what you did yeah y so infrared
is good for looking at the most distant
universe that's running away from us so
fast that the wavelengths are Streed out
into the infrared it's good for looking
through dust clouds where stars are
being born today because the dust
obscures the visible light but doesn't
stop the infrared it's good for looking
at cold things that are not warm enough
to send out their own visible light so
three big reasons to look for infrared
light yeah and then um our astronomy
Community wrote a little book uh that's
was called HST that's Hubble Space
Telescope and Beyond and it's a very
beautiful poetic little book Alan
Dressler was the chair of that committee
and you read this book and you say if we
can possibly do that it's worth
everything we can give it yeah so um and
what year is is this now that's 95 there
the committee was meetting finishing it
up in 95 so okay I get a chance to work
on that that is the next sure thing that
there is for me and the phone call is
around 95 or late 95 okay the day before
Halloween of 95 and then and then you
say to yourself this is it this is going
to be the next project do you see this
as a multi- deade undertaking I didn't
even worry about it I thought I don't
know how long it's going to take I'm
just going to work on it yeah because it
is the it is the thing and uh does it
require that you move to no uh as it
happened we were starting it to run from
NASA Godard where I already was okay so
no I don't have to go anywhere just uh
change my job title right and and so you
start to assemble a team to do this so
the first thing is uh find a a study
manager to work the engineering end of
things so I worked with him for a long
time and we started recruiting more
Engineers so okay we got to design the
telescope we got to find the detectors
we got to say what's the shape of this
whole thing so it can be cold and outer
space yeah what orbit are we going to
some of these things and is this on
paper at we have paper we and
whiteboards and sketches and meetings
and we'll conceive these things together
so then it becomes meetings meetings and
meetings because you can't do a thing
like this alone yeah you have to get a
lot of people to sign up to say this is
what we want to do not just what John
and Bernie want to do right so we're
working along for a little while and we
said we think we know what we want to do
we presented our idea to a conference
where industry teams were there we
thought we were going to just ask them
to build our design they said no go away
come back in an hour we'll tell you what
we think we want you to set up a
competition for industry teams to work
against one another and with
universities to uh actually find the
best idea so okay we'll do that still at
the idea stage still at the very idea
stage yeah so in that very first summer
of 96 we had three teams running two in
un two industry teams plus the NASA team
with Space Telescope Science Institute
so at the end of the summer we had a
week or so of listening to everybody's
presentations and saying okay we got
three answers to how to do this and we
think we know how to calculate the cost
of course that was
wrong but and anyway we knew that the
thing could be done in principle we had
a way to get mirrors we had a way to get
detectors we had various shapes you
could use yeah and was one of those the
one that was actually built or more or
less yeah so at the beginning you don't
really know and um when you choose a
contractor you don't just say um I like
the design better you have to also say
can they really do it yeah and this is
north of Grumman we chose north of
Grumman yeah their competitor wasy
Martin which was also brilliant they
could have done it too but we chose
northr they had some things that they
could tell us uh number one they had
built the Chandra Observatory just
before this one so we knew they could do
a great project which had its own it had
its own incredibly difficult challenges
and they also said by the way we've
already deployed 2,000 things in outer
space and they've all
worked that was pretty convincing yeah
sure not not to say that it was all
perfect but that shows a lot of
engineering yeah smarts and process
control so yeah when you you say this is
going to work you don't just say I know
it's going to work you say I did
something right to prove that it should
work so anyway we had good reasons to
choose them and was the idea that the
NASA team in northr would be working
hand and glove or is it you pass over to
them the uh the final choice and come
back when you're done it has to be hand
and glove because there's so many pieces
from so many parts of the world have to
eventually mesh so for instance NASA was
in charge of the instrument package we
have four instruments from Europe Canada
and the United States they're all stuck
into a gigantic carbon fiber frame and
we assembled that all at Godard
spaceflight Center and we tested it
three times in our vacuum tank yeah I've
been down there you've seen it yeah it's
amazing so anyway NASA was responsible
for that part assembling basically the
international contributions into one box
and then that had to fit onto the
telescope which was uh largely produced
by ball Aerospace and subcontract to
northr and then so when that was all put
together we had to verify that that
would work we did that in a NASA
facility in Houston Texas which turned
out to be the same vacuum tank where the
astronauts rehearsed to land on the Moon
is that right well yeah it's on the
historic register that chamber is so
important and so old and did any of
these tests show failures where you're
like okay that idea didn't work let's go
back and yeah all of them show failures
basically everything shows a failure or
at least something you don't quite
understand so you have to either decide
to change something and fix it or
negotiate around it one way or the other
that's what you do you don't want to go
test all over again every time because
it's hugely expensive timeconsuming
typical test takes six months or a year
because you have to install it in
equipment then you have to cool it down
and you do the test and you warm it up
very carefully Try Not To Break It along
the way and are you handson on these
tests like holding your breath as it's
happening or I not but other people are
yeah yeah other people are sitting there
with a computers of course you're not
touching anything you're touching a
computer keyboard to control it all but
every day you have to figure out what
did yesterday's results mean are we okay
are we have we have we wrecked anything
uh is there anything we need to test
that we weren't thinking of yesterday so
it's a very high energy people required
to run these tests so yeah that's a deal
are there moments in there where you
personally start to question whether
this is going to work no not for me I
just said and there's multiple reasons
one is that's not me I'm I'm not a I
don't give up easy so if it doesn't work
today well we'll keep on at it till it
works tomorrow the other reason of
course was I think it was pretty clear
to everyone that this was the thing that
we were committed to do the NASA was
committed to doing it uh the Congress
and the Senate are committed to doing it
we've invested the entire faith of the
federal process in making this thing
work this is the flagship mission for
NASA yeah so it's got to work which
means that you're not going to scrape
off a little piece to save a little
money doesn't work anyway so we going to
have to make it work and uh it's an
international partnership so we're not
going to embarrass all our international
team members by saying we give up now so
basically the choice says figure out how
to go right now you mentioned with Kobe
that Hubble wound up making funding
difficult during certain stretches did
you have funding issues for web along
the way well of course we did um the
boss that we had at the beginning was
Dan golden he was very Visionary and he
said we really want this telescope when
he announced to the astronomers that we
were going to build it he got a standing
ovation right so okay we know this is
what we need to do but he was the idea
that said how about faster better and
cheaper so we knew that wasn't possible
uh but we said okay boss we'll start and
we'll just work it out as we go along so
yes we had more than once to ask for a
lot more money and um in the process of
course we had to ask for Senator mcy to
help us uh so she wrote us a letter
please explain how you're going to do
this right we don't like it that every
year you come and ask for a few more
dollars yeah this doesn't look good so
we were able to satisfy her request by
getting external review committees to
say number one did good work didn't ask
for enough money number two there's no
other way to do this project right so
that's good enough the Congress can back
something like that so okay so Senator
MOSI made the enough agreements with
enough people that they got the money so
after that we were able to stick to the
plan quite well uh until coid came and
then we had to say well it'll actually
take us a little longer um but we still
came pretty close to the budget we
planned right well and what was the
total the Us Part up to launch 10
billion 10 billion dollar and I don't
know the numbers the Canadians and the
Europeans chipped in but it it was
smaller but rather substantial now we
have quite a friendly audience watching
our conversation here who I think don't
need to be convinced about spending that
kind of money but to The Wider world
what do you say when people wonder about
whether it was worth $10 billion or I
mean it's still ongoing is it worth that
kind of investment yeah so well multiple
parts to that one is um there's no other
way to get this information yeah so if
you want it this is what you get to do
so you know do you want it so the answer
is yes we can afford it as a world we
can certainly afford it it's U what a
dollar or so per person in the world
that doesn't sound like a lot but it's a
lot if you don't have it yeah another
part of the story is we have
demonstrated that as a world we can do
something incredibly complicated if we
decide to do it so that says how about
the other problems we're thinking about
climate change pollution all the kinds
of things that we as a planet have to
think about we can solve that right
takes a little bit of planning and
commitment and more scientists and more
Engineers so please uh notice that we
can do complicated things don't say it's
impossible let said let's go do it yeah
that's my Approach yeah so um there are
a few things which are harder where we
know what we need to do but people don't
agree yet uh so if people think if he
gets it then I don't that's a problem
right uh so we need to establish the
that solving the good problems means
everybody wins which it does of which it
does so I think as President Kennedy
said when we started the Apollo program
we're going to do this not because it's
easy but because it's hard we choose to
go to the moon and this decade and do
the other things not because they are
easy but because they are hard because
that goal will serve to organize and
measure the best of our energies and
skills he promised that it was hard to
deliver on the other things too part it
always is it always is but that's a
point of view to take we are going to do
it yeah so let's take that point of view
and do it so then launch day is set
December December 25th 25th 2021 right
and uh where does the launch take place
and what's that like okay launches in
French Guana yeah on the North coast of
South America U which is actually a
piece of France and why is it there
because it's a French rocket so people
speak French there um but it's a very
international science center uh so I
didn't go there I never have been there
I didn't have any busy business
bothering the people were doing real
work um and hard hardly anybody else
went either only the people that really
needed to be be there with really wow um
it's not a visitor center it's a place
for work and so but you didn't feel that
you were missing out some fumo there
happening no I'm I'm perfectly fine with
watching it on the TV yeah which I did
because uh all our launch parties were
canceled all right we had coid was
dangerous at that time so if you gave Co
to you're member of the team who was
going to supposed to be working in the
control center and that person couldn't
go because you made him sick yeah then
you committed a sin so everybody stay
home so I watched on the sofa with my
wife and oh it was great and it worked
and it worked and then obviously there's
this long whatever six Monon
commissioning period six months to get
it all set up and working and that was
relatively Flawless it was Flawless so
why is it Flawless of course we
practiced yeah so how do you
practice doing something in outer space
when you don't have one so we made a
digital twin we called it the online
test bed so it's a computer simulation
of the entire thing okay um you send
commands to it uh it behaves like the
real thing and to Signal send signals
back as though it were the real thing so
we still use it because every day you
send up a command you want to know am I
doing the right thing uh so you send the
command to the simulator first right
that uh you haven't screwed up and so we
we use it all the time um and it's
important if you're doing something that
you're not familiar with sure
and uh obviously it paid off it uh
unfurled and deployed and and has done
everything that you wanted it to do and
as we began you've already noted that
some of the data is wonderfully
surprising the galaxies at an earlier
time than we would have expected but
even more visual the images when you
compare them side by side with what we
had you know even from Hubble the
difference between them is is really
really remarkable yes it is totally
amazing on my tie I've got the the
nebula where stars are being born today
very nice um and um and we can see
through the dust we can see the stars
shining through the dust cloud we see
the wind blowing through space to
distort the clouds of dust we see the
winds triggering the formation of due
generations of stars and we can begin to
tell stories about how it works and do
the math yeah So eventually we might be
able to tell you how was a star like the
sun with a little bunch of planets
boring around it how does that happen
yeah and there's also wonderful work
being done looking for exoplanets uh
turning the telescope on our own solar
system so it's it's it's really quite
quite
spectacular as you look forward from
this wonderful sequence which I guess
roughly you can summarize is Kobe to
James web onward what's what's the
onward looking like well uh NASA as a
whole has another project we're about to
launch in about 3 four years called the
Nancy Grace Roman Space Telescope it's
uh about the size of Hubble uh but 100
times as much sky at one bite so it's
going to survey the sky looking for rare
objects looking for evidence of dark
matter and dark energy and they're going
to try out a coronograph which is a
device to look for planets around other
stars so and how remind me how
coronograph works coronograph works by
blocking the star light a bright star
and then uh being very careful of got
getting rid of the blocked light so the
problem to be solved is that planets are
very faint compared to the Stars they
orbit around because they only Shine by
reflected light anyway so sun is 10
billion times brighter than the Earth as
seen from the distance now you got to be
really good at blocking that Starlight
or you'll never see the planet so that's
what a coronograph does so we'll try it
out probably not see any little Earths
with it but you will try it then U so
that's the next big NASA project after
that we're probably going to build
something called the habitable world's
Observatory AB worlds um the aim there
is to see Earth orbiting stars like the
sun we got one example of Earth Nam the
one we're on uh so look for other places
where that might happen so so far we've
not found any other systems configured
like the solar system solar system has
four little rocky planets in the middle
yep than a gap then four big gaseous
planets out there cold and um we have
not found any Lum like that elsewhere so
we don't know if that's an essential
feature of the fact that we're Earth can
be alive well well anyway we are hunting
yeah so that's a big project for our
next and what are the dates for these uh
oh well missions the Roman telescope in
about three or four years we're actually
finishing it up at God space flight
center we've got Parts there wiring up
the building the bus and all that stuff
um the habitable worlds may be 20 or
more years depending on how ambitious we
are right um and also uh Lisa Lisa is
coming that's going to look for
gravitational waves uh gravitational
waves have been detected from the ground
with a Observatory here called
ligo and the one in space would be more
sensitive and capable of picking up
lower frequency waves so coming from
black holes merging with uh neutron
stars and U anyway much to be found out
there so that will be exciting yeah
hugely exciting and then we're going to
fly a mission out to Titan which is a
satellite of Saturn that has an
atmosphere yep and we're flying sending
a helicopter to hop around short
distances and examine the surface in
different places they've got rock on the
surface is made out of water ice got
Haze rain clouds lakes rivers made out
of ethane and methane yeah so that's a
good place to look if you think uh there
could be something to be learned about
life of another sort for sure uh we're
sending a probe to orbit the moons of
Jupiter to look for organic molecules
coming out in the water jets from Europa
yeah so if you if that ocean under there
is alive we might see signs of it long
term there are even other Wilder ideas
as you know we've got we're building
huge telescopes the biggest one is the
European one it's 39 meters across which
is six times as big as the web can you
imagine that they're very well Along on
it they're going to have it finished and
taking pictures in a few years I'm
thinking about how to use that kind of
telescope also better uh we have been
working on something called Adaptive
Optics which compensates for the
turbulence of the Earth's atmosphere
gets you a sharp picture yeah and so our
particular idea is to fly a laser beacon
in space to shine down on the telescope
to give you something to focus on so we
think if we could do that then you could
get better performance so we're working
on that part that's still in the theory
stage or yeah we know what to build yeah
but nobody said build it right so we
know we we can buy all the parts that it
takes for that right so that's pretty
cool then here's a really wild idea
let's build a star shade 100 meters
across as big as two football fields
side by side yeah uh and cast a shadow
of a star onto that European telescope
on the ground ah then um you could take
a picture of another solar system in one
minute Venus and Mars could all show up
in one minute so that's pretty powerful
and that's kind of fun to think about
and that's that's in the cogitation
stage that's the citation stage we don't
know really how to build it because it's
so big and so unfamiliar not impossible
I like thinking about things that are
not impossible but U currently we're
working on student challenges to say
okay world's students how would you do
it yeah well that's great yeah and so
just a couple other things how I mean
this is an unanswerable question but
life on other worlds is that something
that you feel intuitively confident
about or no no perspective on it I have
the opinion that it's common and the
reason that we have one data point um
which is not that we've only examined
one Earth it is that when life appeared
on Earth it happened very quickly after
we got oceans yeah and we know this from
the geological record so fossils or or
geological strata that say ocean a
little while later geological Strata
with Signs of Life yeah maybe a few
hundred million years so that says well
this what we used to guess was that uh
life is required in extremely rare
circumstance my guess is the opposite
life will happen immediately given the
chance yeah so we just don't know what
takes to give it a chance and the reason
we haven't seen any they're just too far
away or too far away and too hard yeah
we haven't gotten any rocks back from
Mars yet yeah not on purpose anyway
though we picked up a few meteorites we
are collecting them to bring them back
our our Rovers over there on Mars are
picking up rocks and putting them in
little storage spots to be brought home
right there are other places to look
meteors come in occasionally we look to
see what have they got in them so for we
do see organic chemicals sure
but you cannot see that they're produced
by life what about intelligent
life well here we are uh it's been the
entire history of the universe 13.8
billion years for us to turn up yeah and
we've only been here a momentary yeah so
it's not unlikely that intelligent life
will always occur somewhere but it takes
time yeah so we don't know what governs
the time scale for evolution but it's
been billions of years for us to get
here for sure and so if you were to lay
out one question one discovery that you
would place as the Pinnacle of things
that you would like to learn during your
hopefully long but remaining time on
planet Earth what would you what would
you say well right now I would say the
question of is life
unique is really
interesting so if we could find signs
that there was life elsewhere in the
solar system or on a planet around
another star I would be thrilled yeah I
think I think my my guess I've made a
guess yeah what the answer is but that
doesn't mean we can find it yeah so Mars
is awfully unpleasant right now so if
there are signs of life it might be
fossils only and how would we find them
so going to Mars and picking up a few
rocks on the surface is not like
guaranteed to work
yeah but you would put that as the I
think that would be a thrilling
discovery it absolutely would be it's
been on my mind since I was a little guy
yeah that would bring it all full circle
it sure would well let's hope that that
question we answer that at some point
and it's always a pleasure talking to
you John thanks so much for thank you
Brian that the conversation and look
forward to more thank
[Music]
you